what have been the three biggest
mistakes you guys have made uh maybe up
to sort of six nine months ago the
market was super super boy and and
recruitment companies doing really
really well everybody's making lots of
money and this is not just crypto this
is like the wide attack recruitment in
general I think our standards were
slipping in that period and it's really
hard when you like look at a sales team
you know you've got people who have only
ever known one market so they vote
they've only ever known good times when
it was as good as it was it breeds
complacency and we knew for a wheel like
this is going to end it's so difficult
to try and enforce certain standards
when everyone's doing deals and
everyone's doing well and it's been like
why are you on my back about this it's
so hard to like communicate that to
people a lot of the time they have to
live it themselves